before i move on to a more complicated
example i thought i would touch on a
point that i made in the previous
partial fractions one video and i wasn't
able to kind of completely complete and
that was just the idea of how do we
solve this equation right here and just
a a little bit of review of how we got
here and if if you don't know how we got
here this looks completely unfamiliar
you should watch the partial fractions
one video but we said that this this
rational expression can be written as
the sum of these two simpler rational
expressions and when you add these two
fractions or these two expressions you
get this it's you just found a common
denominator and then you multiply this
times the denominator of the other one
multiply this times the denominator of
the other expression and we got this
here and then the denominators are the
same so now we just have to set the
numerators equal to each other and
that's where we got this right here and
i had mentioned in the last video that
there's two ways to solve this problem
and the the fast way and then the way
that at least i was taught when i was in
i forgot when eighth or ninth grade and
i suspect that it's still the way that
it's taught in a lot of schools so i
wanted to teach you that way just so you
don't do it the other way and you know
some teachers are very particular about
how you do a problem even though that's
completely correct so i thought i would
at least expose you to the way that your
teacher or your school might want you to
do it and it's also an interesting way
and it might be relevant to solving
other types of problems so just as a
review in the last video to solve this i
just set x to to be values that would
make the a or the b disappear so if x
equals minus 5
i picked minus 5 because it makes this
expression 0. so it cancels out the a
you're left with minus 5 plus 3
is equal to 0 plus b times minus five
minus eight that's exactly what we did
in the last video and if you just
solve for this you get what b is equal
to
two over thirteen if i remember
correctly and then i picked x is equal
to eight to make this equal to zero and
that made us eight plus three
is equal to
a times eight plus five
plus now this expression would be zero
zero and then you just get a is equal to
what it's 11 over 13. and we were done
and then we knew what our our i guess
decomposed fractions are or i guess the
partial fractions of this larger one i i
don't know exactly how that that that
terminology should apply exactly but you
get the point
the other way to solve this and this way
i was exposed to it let me write that in
green
to show that i'm just continuing this
part of the problem just solving a
different way is to multiply out this
expression so just to write out the
whole thing is
x plus 3
is equal to and i'm going to multiply it
out
a
x
plus
5 a
plus b x
minus 8b
and then to group the
x terms and then the
and then the constant terms and you get
x
plus 3 is equal to
ax plus b x
plus
5 a
minus 8 b notice i just grouped the x
terms and i grouped the constant terms
and then you could say x plus 3
is equal to we can factor out an x here
a plus b
times x
plus
5 a
minus 8 b
and then the realization you have to do
at this point you say okay if i'm adding
these two things up and i get this
a plus b so all the things that involve
x are right here
these are all the things that so this
has to be equal to this
right there's no way that i you know i
could substitute some type of a's and
b's here that would somehow contribute
to the three and likewise
the constant terms
have to add up to the three
and you use that insight to essentially
set up a system of equations
so you say well a plus b
that's the coefficient on the x term on
this side well that has to be equal to
the coefficient of the x term on that
side and the coefficient on the x term
right here is 1. it's not written but
it's implicitly 1 times x so you can
write down the equation
let me do it in that light blue color a
plus b have to equal 1.
and then the constant terms have to add
up to 3 so you could write
five a
minus eight b
is equal to
three and then you have a system of of
two equations two unknowns and you solve
it like the way you you always learn to
solve it and let me do it
right here so
there's a couple of ways you could do by
substitution you could multiply both
equations actually an interesting thing
let's multiply this top equation by
eight so then you get eight a
plus eight b
is equal to eight right i just
multiplied all the terms by eight and
now we can add these two equations and i
did that so that these cancel out so
eight a plus five a is thirteen a
eight b minus eight b that's zero
is equal to 8 plus 3 is 11 and then you
get
13 a is equal to 11
a is equal to 11 over 13. and then you
could use this information and you
substitute it back
into this and that original equation i
mean you could substitute it back into
eight a plus eight b is equal to eight
or you could substitute it back into a
plus b
is equal to one and you get 11 over 13
plus b is equal to one or b is equal to
well another way to write 1 is 13 over
13 minus 11 over 13 and that's 2 over
13.
so you can see there's a huge difference
in the amount of time and frankly the
amount of errors you can make when you
do it this way but this is the way
at least in
louisiana in the
late 80s it was taught
anyway actually i'll leave you in this
video in the next video i'll start a
more complicated problem